so beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive
the sun's out you dare and come this
house
you
so beautiful day to be alive uncle Joey
here on point [ __ ] June 4th 2017 it
can't get no better than this
the birds are chirpin the sun's out the
clouds are gone and you're [ __ ] up
ready to swing Vic like you've never
smile Vic before it's a whole new week
it's a whole new set of priorities
it's [ __ ] son name this isn't getting
it ready for [ __ ] Monday because the
rest of these humps the drinking
cocktail they want to reach celebratin
whatever the [ __ ] they got to celebrate
but your focus same time you're writing
your goals you're listing all the things
you want to do this week and what
expects to be happening you follow me
everybody else is [ __ ] around oh I
love mocha Lanka chinos who gives a [ __ ]
I like [ __ ] reefer and taking good
care of myself and after Sunday's are
about [ __ ] I do Jitsu
I got a nice dinner with the [ __ ]
family he had a couple spots you had the
improv night but [ __ ] Comedy Store
you know what man it's the Lord's me but
it don't [ __ ] end only [ __ ] jerk
models take the lord's day off or the
other [ __ ] day off there's a burn up
since 6 o'clock working picked up Magoo
[ __ ] you understand me getting
ready for the next booking six months
ahead
everybody's always saying the months
flew by education up a pathway if the
month flies by to me she ain't doing
dick the munchin [ __ ] flyby out there
banging every [ __ ] day you're
following me but enough is enough you
had a great week coming up whatever
happened last week you don't know
nothing you don't know nothing you don't
want to know nothing that was last week
this is this [ __ ] week you
follow me you're gonna be a whole new
person just like me every week you get
bad a little strong like the Six Million
Dollar Man you get [ __ ] and stronger
better physically mentally and
spiritually alert you follow me what am
i smoke pathetic oh [ __ ] he think I'm
smoking after Larry og and I got the
perennial hold as usual taking good care
and Joey after I do this um have a
little protein shake I'm going on a weed
store to respect for the [ __ ] weak I
got stopped by the one I Jews house and
get that envelope taken care of and
that's my [ __ ] Sunday you
understand me but the most important
thing about a Sunday is what's come the
next five days what look Joey what's
with the [ __ ] he'd be in a spot or
what I'm telling you I'm telling you
home look at that you know that smells
like victory [ __ ] you know
bulls I don't mean Oh bills I don't need
no [ __ ] is that a van I'm a nothing for
nothing
this is the only chemical uncle Joey
[ __ ] around but you know what it's time
for another one it's time for another
little Bowl here just as there's no
misunderstanding is the shipping Noriega
smoked last week before he died you
follow anyway we're here with weird what
do I got this week oh [ __ ]
we got a podcast Monday night we got a
podcast Wednesday but the most important
thing is brain [ __ ] let me tell you
something but before the podcast cam and
this whole thing to manager Brad might
be at joey's
yes I believe in you there's some of
much I like I want you to host down here
one man one night a month probably go
down a [ __ ] Brea and when we first
did it six people showed up then [ __ ]
12 people showed up and 18 showed up
about a year later we had the place back
now we started that [ __ ] from
zero heart and balls so do me a [ __ ]
favor you're not doing nothing Thursday
Friday and Saturday
let's hit [ __ ] brass one of the
best rooms in the country they have to
[ __ ] mall there but most importantly
that room is built for [ __ ] comedy
and this time that's white paper TV you
want a priest my first CD so Tamiya's
got a lot of value to it I do well in my
room so if you're not doing anything
Thursday 8 o'clock it's going to be all
over with the show being that way myself
and Kate [ __ ] we believe you
understand what type of show that'll be
stars muffin listen we'll have stars
when I'm missing kids down there
come on down Thursday nights plus on
that Friday sadly two shows it's going
to be a great [ __ ] weekend brer you
can have a good [ __ ] time what else
is good hey much going on man who try to
do this I'm trying to do that I'm trying
to get you shape I'm trying to be
healthy you know I'm getting my sleep
and that's all that matters I never took
care of myself like this before but few
[ __ ]
you make me scuff up to the [ __ ]
employment yeah protection we do one
more respect
[ __ ] it let's do one more respect
because I can sing you [ __ ] in
a few days congratulation to max
Holloway last night being a mouth off
how do they know where he was last night
again congratulations to the cute girl
with the ponytail come out on a
celebrating Edina we know both why don't
know what the [ __ ] happened there and it
was a good fight I saw the I saw has
three fights I was [ __ ] busy
understand me but congratulations to the
new champion max Halliwell a
[ __ ] went from zero to
[ __ ] hero he took a beating
from what's-his-name he didn't get
knocked down either it was a decision
from [ __ ] the Irish kid and he hasn't
turned around him he hasn't turned
around one time you gotta you gotta
think about when things like that happen
what he do what was his preparation what
was his mindset he's [ __ ] amazing 25
year old kid there you are 25 you can't
[ __ ] put it together you still making
sandwiches at Subway you follow me
gotta put together too young dude I
didn't have nothing going on at 25 but I
had a hard [ __ ] I wasn't working for
the right thousand hours I've been
[ __ ] doing my thing
but anyway that's it and that's that you
guys [ __ ] I'll be doing another
one of these tonight from somewhere and
then Monday Wednesday and and Brea this
week on all right have a great day with
your family
remember what your family you got stick
go hang out with some golden kisses go
Tom you love them and accent nice damn
uncle Joey I'm playing as usual
smoking his brief but most importantly I
ain't bothering nobody I don't have a
crew of guys with me jumping up and down
I don't need that [ __ ] just new concepts
stay black have a good day